THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT
ANGLE.
THE INTEGRITY OF OUR ELECTIONS
IS IMPERILED TONIGHT.
WE MAY BE WITNESSING ANOTHER IN
A SERIES OF STOLEN ELECTIONS IN
FLORIDA.
DEMOCRATS ARE EXPERTS AT PULLING
US WITH THESE AT THE BALLOT BOX.
IT'S WIDELY BELIEVED TO
-- THEY MAY
BE UP TO THEIR OLD TRICKS AGAIN.
BALLOT IRREGULARITIES IN
PALM BEACH AND BROWARD COUNTIES
IN FLORIDA ARE FRONT AND CENTER.
THE PRESIDENT, OF COURSE, HAS
BEEN VERY VOCAL ABOUT WHAT HE
BELIEVES IS HAPPENING THERE.
>> WELL, YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE
PAST.
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN THEY ARE
FINDING VOTES?
AFTER THE ELECTION THEY ARE
>> Laura: PREDICTABLY, THE
MEDIA HAS COME IN TO POOH-POOH
ANY NOTION OF VOTER FRAUD.
>> TO BE VERY CLEAR, AND I WANT
TO MAKE SURE EVERYBODY AT HOME
UNDERSTANDS, THERE IS NO
EVIDENCE TO THAT STORY.
IT NEVER HAPPENED.
>> Laura: "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
YESTERDAY WROTE, NO ONE HAS
OFFERED EVIDENCE OF WIDESPREAD
ELECTION FRAUD.
NO ONE?
I LOVE THE WEASEL WORD
WIDESPREAD, NEATO.
IF 1-2 COUNTIES ARE ENGAGED IN
VOTER FRAUD, IT IS WIDESPREAD.
IT AFFECTS THE RESULTS PERHAPS
FOR THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
LET'S EXAMINE THE FACTS.
THINGS ARE SO BAD IN PALM BEACH,
GOVERNOR RICK SCOTT, WHO WAS IN
A TIGHT SENATE RACE, SEE WOULD
BE SUPERVISOR OF ELECTIONS SUSAN
BUCHER.
JUDGE RULED THAT SHE HAD
WITHHELD UNDER VOTED AND OVER
VOTED -- HE IS ALLOWED PUBLIC
SCRUTINY OF THE BALLOTS.
SCOTT HAS VOWED TO FIGHT BACK
PLAYING FAST AND LOOSE WITH THE
VOTER'S WILL.
>> I WILL NOT SIT IDLY BY WHILE
UNETHICAL LIBERALS TRY TO STEAL
THIS ELECTION FROM THE GREAT
PEOPLE OF FLORIDA.
>> Laura: THE GOVERNOR HAS
ALSO VIEWED BROWARD COUNTY
ELECTION SUPERVISOR -- HER OWN
ROCK STAR THESE DAYS BRENDA
SNIPES.
SNIPES IS A PIECE OF WORK.
HER PREDECESSOR LITERALLY WALKED
OUT OF HER OFFICE IN 2003 FOR A
GRAVE AND NEGLECT MISMANAGEMENT
AND INCOMPETENCE.
PRACTICALLY A TRADITION DOWN
THERE IN BROWN
BROWARD.
A JUDGE FOUND HER GUILTY OF
ILLEGALLY DESTROYING BALLOTS
DURING A PRIMARY ELECTION IN
2016.
IN AUGUST, A COURT FOUND HER
GUILTY OF SECRETLY OPENING MAIL
IN BALLOTS, WHICH IS ILLEGAL IN
HER STATE.
ON FRIDAY, GOVERNOR SCOTT WON A
LAWSUIT AGAINST SNIPES.
IN THIS ELECTION, SHE CONTINUED
TO DISCOVER NEW BALLOTS.
SHE WAS FOUND IN VIOLATION OF
THE STATE'S PUBLIC RECORDS LAW
AND HAS BEEN ORDERED TO RELEASE
INFORMATION TO GOVERNOR SCOTT.
SO FAR?
SHE HASN'T COMPLIED WITH THE
ORDER.
>> YOU REFUSED TO GIVE THE SCOTT
CAMPAIGN THE INFORMATION THEY
WANTED AND HAD TO GO TO COURT.
THE JUDGE SAID YOU HAD TO TURN
IT OVER.
YOU DIDN'T TURN IT OVER BY THE
DEADLINE THAT WAS GIVEN.
THAT IS CAST AS A PARTISANS FAT,
THAT YOU ARE DOING THAT BECAUSE
YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT.
HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO THAT?
>> I WAS SPEAKING WITH THE WOMAN
TODAY AND SHE CAME IN THE OFFICE
AND SHE MADE SOME STATEMENT
ABOUT A PARTISANS STATEMENT, AND
SHE SAID I KNOW YOU ARE A
REPUBLICAN.
I SAID I HAVE BEEN A DEMOCRAT
ALL MY LIFE.
IN THIS POSITION, I HAVE BEEN
VERY FOCUSED ON PARTY BECAUSE I
WANT TO TREAT ALL OF THE VOTERS
IN BROWARD COUNTY THE SAME.
WE DON'T SELECT WHO WE GIVE OUT
INFORMATION TO.
WE GIVE INFORMATION TO THOSE
PERSONS WHO HAVE REQUESTED IT.
I BELIEVE THE PUBLIC RECORDS
REQUEST A IN A TIMELY MATTER.
WE ATTEMPT TO DO THAT.
>> Laura: AND...
WAIT A SECOND.
DID SHE ACTUALLY HEAR THE
QUESTION?
THIS WOMAN IS UNBELIEVABLE.
THE "MIAMI HERALD" REPORTS THAT
AN ELECTION WORKER FOUND BAGS OF
UNCOUNTED EARLY BALLOTS IN THE
BROWARD COUNTY ELECTIONS OFFICE.
SNIPES ALSO MINGLED REJECTED THE
PROVISIONAL BALLOTS WITH THE
ACCEPTED ONES AND THEN SHE
PROCEEDED TO COUNT THEM ALL IN
THE OFFICIAL VOTE COUNTY!
NEATO.
NOW A RECOUNT IS UNDERWAY WHERE
THE COUNTERS MUST DISCERN THE
INTENT OF THE VOTERS IF THERE IS
A MARK ON THE BALLOT HERE OR
THERE.
MY FRIENDS, THIS IS A COMPLETE
TRAVESTY THAT CANNOT BE
PERMITTED TO CHANGE THE OUTCOME
OF THIS ELECTION.
IT SADLY IS NOT RESTRICTED TO
THE SUNSHINE STATE.
WE ARE GOING TO SHOW YOU WHAT
DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING IN GEORGIA
IN JUST MOMENTS.
SO WHAT IS NEXT?
I THINK AS THE KAVANAUGH FIGHT
DEMONSTRATED, THE REPUBLICANS
MUST STAND UNITED TO EXPOSE THE
MOUSE REASONS AND THE FRAUD OF
THE LEFT.
WHEN WE DO, WE USUALLY WIN.
WE CANNOT ALLOW THIS FLOUTING OF
THE RULES AND PROCEDURES BY
CORRUPT OFFICIALS OR POLITICAL
HACKS, CANNOT LET IT STAND.
IF WE ALLOW THIS TO GO UNCHECKE
UNCHECKED, IT WILL UNDERMINE OUR
DEMOCRACY, AND LIKE A CONTAGION
IT'S GOING TO SPREAD ACROSS THE
NATION.
18 YEARS?
CAN YOU BELIEVE IT, SINCE BUSH V
GORE?
IT'S ABSOLUTELY UNBELIEVABLE
THAT WE ARE STILL DEALING WITH
THESE TYPE OF ISSUES.
IT IS TIME FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO STEP IN AND DO A TOP
TO BOTTOM INVESTIGATION
REGARDING WHY THESE ISSUES STILL
PERSIST.
IF NECESSARY, PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO HAVE TO GO TO JAIL.
THERE HAS TO BE REPERCUSSIONS
FOR WILLFUL FRAUDULENT DEFIANCE
OF ELECTORAL LAWS.
IF THIS ISN'T CLEANED UP, I'M
TELLING YOU, THE G.O.P. CAN KISS
ANY HOPES OF RESTORING THEIR